neben der detektion von strahlung ist es
wichtig geschützt zu sein und daher zu
wissen wieviel dosis einzelne personen
aufnehmen beim bundesheer gibt es dazu
zwei systeme die eingeführt sind das
thermometer sense dosimeter das als
persönliches dose peta verwendet wird
das kann man nicht direkt ablesen
sondern das wird erst im nachhinein
ausgewertet und dann erfährt man sehr
genau und sehr detailliert wie viel
großes man über den vergangenen zeitraum
aufgenommen hat und zum direkten
feststellen einer möglichen erhöhten
dosis ein elektronisches personen
dosimeter dass man direkt ablesen kann
und dementsprechend außen am schutzanzug
trägt so ist man immer gewarnt wenn die
dose ist immer aktuell verfügbar hat
steigt und man sich möglicherweise einen
gefährlichen umfeld befindet